EVERYONE TO THE MAY FIRST
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE -- AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM -- SO WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR ALL MEMBERS TO
PLEASE JOIN US IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM.
WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE I SEE MR BLOOM IS
HERE.
FIRST ON THE LIST FILE ITEM
THREE A. B..
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE MR BLOOM
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS -- THIS
BILL WILL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON
THEM.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL ALLOW
NONPROFIT PUBLIC PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATIONS TO SELL BONDS THAT
OUR STATE INCOME TAXEXEMPT TO
FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS I NEED TO TELL
YOU GUYS THIS HOW MANY HOUSING
UNITS WE NEED AND HOW.
HOW HAVE NEVER HEARD ABOUT ANY
SORT OF ALL HOUSING BUT -- AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE LIKE MANY OF
THE BILLS THAT ARE MOVING
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE -- IN
THIS SESSION OFFER A SOLUTION
NOT THE ONLY SOLUTION BUT A
SOLUTION.
OF THE BILL WILL ALLOW THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES TO CREATE THE
STATE'S FIRST HOUSING FINANCE
CORPORATION A SELF SUSTAINING
LOCAL HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY.
THE LA HOUSING FINANCE
CORPORATION WILL SELL TAX.
IT WILL SELL STATE INCOME TAX
EXEMPT BONDS AT BELOW MARKET
RATE.
BOND PROCEEDS WILL THEN FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
BE USED TO OFFER BELOW MARKET
RATE MORTGAGES TO LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME HOME BUYERS.
REPAYMENTS ON MORTGAGE LOANS
WILL BE USED TO PAY FOR THE
PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST ON THE
BONDS AND FINANCE THE AGENCIES
OVERHEAD COSTS.
EXCESS REVENUE WILL FIND MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS IN
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
[inaudible]
HOME BUYERS.
NEW YORK AND RHODE ISLAND'S
FINANCING CORPORATIONS HAVE
SHOWN MAJOR SUCCESSES IN
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT'S WHY WE THINK THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA.
NEW YORK CITY'S HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS
FINANCED OVER A HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS
AND PLANS TO PRODUCE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX PRETTY
AMBITIOUS BUT IT'S THE KIND OF
AMBITION THAT WE NEED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA RHODE ISLAND HAS
FINANCED OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
UNITS.
AND HAS HELPED OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND FAMILIES BY THEIR HOMES
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL HELP
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
THE SUCCESSES OF NEW YORK AND
RHODE ISLAND BY PROVIDING
NONPROFIT AGENCIES.
A TOOL TO ADDRESS OUR CONTINUED
HOUSING CRISIS.
THE AGENCY WILL FIND A PROJECTED
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS AND
ADDITIONALLY THE SELF SUSTAINING
MODEL DOESN'T.
NOT REQUIRE INVESTMENTS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OR ANY TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL BE A
TOOL FOR CITIES TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND SYLVIA STRAW IS HERE
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND DISCUSS THE
BILL FURTHER AN ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. FOR THE
C. LOS ANGELES HELLO GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SELL THIS
ALISHA ON BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI --
WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK AND FOR THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL -- WE THINK THIS IS A
VERY INNOVATIVE SOLUTION --
BASED ON THE NEW YORK MODEL THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM DESCRIBED --
THIS BY HOUSING FINANCE
CORPORATION WOULD WORK ALONG
WITH OUR OTHER -- LOCALS AS
FUNDING MEASURES SUCH AS PROP
HHH FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING ARE
LINKAGE FEE AND WE EXPECT THAT
THIS AGENCY WILL LEVERAGE
PRIVATE CAPITAL MARKET
INVESTMENT.
OUR GOAL IS TO CREATE AT LEAST
SIX HUNDRED UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE FIRST YEAR AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED UNITS THE
SECOND YEAR.
AND GRADUALLY SCALING UP TO
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED UNITS PER
YEAR AFTER FIVE YEARS OF
OPERATION -- AS A SELF GOVERNING
INDEPENDENT AGENCY -- THIS WILL
BE WILL BE ITS OWN ENTITY
SEPARATE FROM THE CITY.
AND THE UNIQUE STRUCTURE OF THE
HOUSING AGENCY WILL ALLOW US TO
LEVERAGE EVERY DOLLAR OF BONDS
ISSUED TO TO CREATE TWELVE FIFTY
OF AFFORDABLE.
HOUSING -- SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS INNOVATIVE
AMBITIOUS TOOL THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY WISH
TO SUPPORT THIS.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC.
WANT TO OPPOSE THIS.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER GLORIA JUST A
QUICK CLARIFYING QUESTION I
THINK I KNOW THE ANSWER BUT
GIVEN THE SPONSOR THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT'S OF
RESTRICTED SCOPE TO THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES CRACKED.
SO THIS WOULD BE STATEWIDE.
OF IMPACT WE HAVE -- SOME TOOLS
LIKE THIS IN SAN DIEGO --
BACKING TO EXPRESS CONNECTION --
FOR THE OPENING UP OF IT MAY BE
BENEFICIAL TO OUR FOLKS AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL -- HAPPY WITH IT WHEN THE
TIME COMES.
THANK YOU.
BUT SORT OF THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
A BRING IN ANOTHER INNOVATIVE
SOLUTION -- MOVING AFFORD I KNOW
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS HAS
BEEN REQUESTED BY THE CITY OF LA
BUT HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE SOME
BROADER IMPACTS AND I HAVE A
BILL THAT -- THE CHAIR OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS -- SUPPORTED THAT
WOULD ALLOW US IN THE BAY AREA
TO MOVE FOR A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
HOUSING ENTITY BUT I THINK WE
ALL NEED DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS TO
GET TO WHERE WE NEED TO GO. TO
DRESS A CRISIS AND APPRECIATE
YOU.
MOVING THIS FOR ALSO APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING A MAN'S TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE INSURING OVERSIGHT
AND TRANSPARENCY AND AT THE
RIGHT TIME I WILL ALSO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO SUPPORT THE SOME OF
IT.
FOR BIGGEST SHARE THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE TO MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
FILE ITEM ONE AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
INSURES THE TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES WHICH ARE SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS SACRED SITES WILL
NOT BE DESTROYED UNDER THE NEW
STREAMLINED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
LAW.
THESE TRIBAL CULTURAL RESOURCES
CAN BE ARCHAEOLOGICAL SITES
FEATURES OR RELIGIOUS OBJECTS
JUST TO NAME A FEW WE HAVE LOST
MUCH OF OUR STATES NATIVE
HISTORY AND ONCE RELIGIOUS OR
CULTURAL ARTIFACT SITE A BURIAL
GROUND IS LOST IT CANNOT BE
REPLACED.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SOME
PROGRESS TOWARD PROTECTING AND
RESPECTING TRIBAL CULTURE
RESOURCES.
AB FIFTY TWO WHICH BECAME LAW IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE CAR
REQUIRES CONSULTATION BY LEAD
AGENCIES UNDERSEA QUIRK WITH
TRIBES THAT HAVE AN INTEREST IN
THE AREA OF A PROPOSED PROJECT.
THERE IS OFTEN NO REASON WHY
DEVELOPER MAY KNOW THAT A
PROJECT SITE IS A PLACE OF
TRIBAL CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE.
WITH CONSULTATION TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCE CAN BE
PROTECTED OR VIA AVOIDED AND
IMPACTS CAN BE MITIGATED.
DEVELOPMENT CAN ACTUALLY MOVE
FASTER WITH CONSULTATION BECAUSE
LITIGATION IS LESS NECESSARY AS
A MEANS OF PROTECTION FOR THE
TRIBES.
SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH BECAME LAW
LAST YEAR DID NOT INCLUDE TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES IN ITS LIST
OF PROTECTED RESOURCES WE ASSUME
THIS IS JUST A SIMPLE OVERSIGHT.
WHAT I SICK WITH THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT THE REQUIREMENT FOR
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES WHOSE
RESOURCES MAY BE VULNERABLE TO A
PROPOSED PROJECT?
THIS IS CLARIFIED BY THE
AMENDMENT I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT IN SUMMARY AS
TRIBAL CULTURE RESOURCE TO THE
LIST OF EXEMPTIONS UNDER SB.
THIRTY FIVE TO ENSURE THE TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES RESOURCES ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO UNWITTING
DESECRATION IN OUR WERE THE
FIGHT TO CREATE MORE HOUSING.
WE CONSULTED WITH SENATOR
WIENERS OFFICE PRIOR TO
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL AND A
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME
TODAY IS MICHELLE A LOW PAYMENT.
THE PENA IN AFRICA FARGAS.
YOUR WITNESSES.
A GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN -- FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL I HAD HOPED TO
HAVE THIS LAST YEAR BUT IT WAS A
WE WERE UNABLE TO GET IT
INCLUDED IN THE LAW AND THE
AMENDMENTS TO SB THIRTY FIVE
LAST YEAR -- AS THEY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN SAID THE WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS AN OVERSIGHT AND SB
THIRTY FIVE THE STREAMLINING
BILL.
BECAUSE TRIBES HAVE AND THEIR
ADVOCATES OF WORK FOR SEVERAL
DECADES NOW.
TO GET SOME PROTECTIONS IN LAW
FOR TRIBAL CULTURAL SITES
CULTURAL PLACES BURIAL GROUNDS --
AND IT'S MOST RECENTLY IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
NEGOTIATED WITH DEVELOPMENT.
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTATIVES
AND THE LEGISLATORS AND THEIR
CONSTITUENTS TO GET AB FIFTY TWO
PASSED AND AB FIFTY TWO WAS.
A PROCESS WHERE DEVELOPERS COULD
BE IN CONSULTATION WITH
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES THAT
HAD KNOWLEDGE OF THESE PLACES
AND WHAT WAS UNDER THE GROUND --
NOT TO BE FLIP BUT I WAS
THINKING ON THE WAY HERE ABOUT
OF THE MOVIE POLTERGEIST RIGHT
WHERE EVERYBODY SEEN POLTERGEIST
IN THE AT THAT YOU FIND OUT AT
THE END OF THE MOVIE THIS
THERE'S A BURIAL GROUND UNDER
THE HOUSING SUBDIVISION.
AND THAT IS A PROBLEM AND THAT'S
FICTION RIGHT THAT'S THE MOVIES
IT'S IN THE MOVIES BUT THIS
ACTUALLY HAPPENS IN REAL LIFE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT TODAY WERE TRYING TO
PREVENT.
PEOPLE FROM KNOWINGLY BUILDING
ON THESE CULTURAL PLACES THAT
AFFECT TRADITIONAL CULTURAL
VALUES -- WE DO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GREATLY
BECAUSE MANY OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRIBES ARE LOW INCOME FOLKS AND
NEED LOW INCOME HOUSING IN THESE
URBAN AREAS -- AND WE DO SUPPORT
THOSE EFFORTS WE JUST ASK THAT
AB FIFTY TO BE RECOGNIZED AND
FOLLOWED.
ADAM AND THE WAY THAT WE CAN DO
THAT IS TO HAVE THE EXEMPTION --
WORKED INTO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S AFFECT
VARGAS -- AND ON BEHALF OF THE
RING CONN BAND OF REALLY SENIOR
INDIANS ALSO DRY CREEK RANCHERIA
WERE STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE HERCULEAN EFFORT
THE ONE IN THE AB.
FIFTY TWO AND WE ARE RESPECTFUL
OF THOSE DEALS THAT WERE
NEGOTIATED BACK THEM -- AND
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US
MOVING FORWARD IN THIS PROCESS
WE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
THE AUTHORING THIS BILL THE ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND CVA ARE NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL.
GREAT LET'S MOVE TO OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
LEARN OUT TAKING TIME HERE FOR
THE BROWN A BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAM MAPLE ON BEHALF
OF THAT POEM OF UPPER LIKE BAND
IN SPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MASS AND WHY ON
BEHALF OF WORLD RENTERIA IN
SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR MOVING THIS FOR THEM A 100%
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO
THE CALLS THIS BILL TO PROTECT
TRAVEL CULTURAL RESOURCES.
I ALSO WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR ACCEPTING OUR COMMITMENTS
WHICH AT THIS TIME IS INTENT
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
NEW PROTECTIONS.
CAN OCCUR WITHOUT PRECLUDING
DEVELOPERS FROM USING THE
STREAMLINED PROCESS SEES --
ESTABLISHING SB THIRTY FIVE I DO
KNOW AND EXPECT A PROBABLY A
LITTLE MORE WORK ON THIS -- ON
THESE AMENDMENTS -- WILL BE
TRACKING THE BILL BUT OUR HOPE
IS THAT THIS WILL MOVE FORWARD
AND I KNOW YOU PROBABLY HAVE A
FEW MORE CONVERSATIONS WITH
CENTER WINNER BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
WE INSURE BOTH OF THESE THINGS
AND I THINK WE CAN EASILY DO
THAT WITH THE SPELL SO WITH THAT
HAPPY.
TO SUPPORT THIS MOVING FORWARD
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES.
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WITH IT FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND OUR LAST BILL PRESENTATION
FOR TODAY IS FILE ITEM TO AB
EIGHT THIRTY TO MISTER GIBSON
[inaudible]
DON'T [inaudible]
YEAH.
ACTUALLY THIS TIME WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM -- TO MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL.
WE HAVE.
FIVE IN THE BACK.
IN THE BACK FINISHING HIS
BREAKFAST.
JUST WANNA CAPTURE CAPTURE THE
GENIE IN THE BOTTLE.
CHIU HERE HERE DAVE YOU'RE HERE
GABRIELLE GABRIELLE HERE GLORIA.
GLORIA HERE KILEY LEE MON
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA QUIRK
SILVA HERE RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS --
LET ME THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BO EIGHT
THIRTY TWO WHICH WILL HELP LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BECOME
HOMEOWNERS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S FACING.
A HOUSING CRISIS THAT LACKS
AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. TO HELP ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS THE PROPOSAL WOULD
STIMULATE PRIVATE INVESTMENTS.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGH A
TAX CREDIT THIS TAX CREDIT WOULD
INCENTIVIZE ON DONORS TO
CONTRIBUTE -- TO NONPROFIT
BUILDINGS HOMES FOR LOW INCOME
AND VERY LOW INCOME FAMILIES
SPECIFICALLY THESE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE BUILDING --
LONG TERM RESALE INDEED
RESTRICTION HOMES TO BE SOLD TO
FAMILIES WHO INCOME IS 3280% --
OF THE LOW AREA -- MEDIUM INCOME
THIS TAX CREDIT AIMS TO ENSURE
THAT THESE HOMES REMAIN
AFFORDABLE AND IN OUR COMMUNITY
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. EIGHT THIRTY
TO OUR REPRESENTATIVES FROM.
I AM THIS SECTOR RECTOR WHO WAS
SELF PRODUCED FROM THE HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY'S CALIFORNIA MIGHT
ADD THAT THIS BILL -- PASS OUT
OF REVAN TAX AND RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
REGISTER OPPOSITION THAT I KNOW
OF THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DEBBIE AYE CALLIN AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING OUR
FORTY ONE HABITAT AFFILIATES
THAT OPERATE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND PRIOR TO THIS ROLE I WAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
WORLD NEVADA COUNTY HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY.
AND AS A FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
NON PROFIT AFFORDABLE HOME
PROVIDER WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT THIRTY TWO BECAUSE IT WILL
LEAD TO MORE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE DESPERATELY NEED TO INCREASE
OUR HOUSING STOCK IN CALIFORNIA
PERIOD BUT WE ESPECIALLY NEED TO
PROVIDE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES THIS
BILL WILL HELP INCREASE
AFFORDABLE HOME AND OWNERSHIP.
BY INCREASING RESOURCES FOR
NONPROFIT BUILDERS.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY SERVICE
FAMILIES EARNING 3280% AREA
MEDIAN INCOME THIS IS OUR TARGET
POPULATION OUR HOMES ARE DEED
RESTRICTED TO REMAIN AFFORDABLE
AND WE INCLUDE SHARED EQUITY
AGREEMENTS.
ARE DESCRIBED IN THIS BILL
SIMILAR LEGISLATION ALREADY
SUPPORTS RENTALS AND THIS BILL
WOULD HELP INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOME OWNERSHIP HELPING TO
BALANCE THE OWNER OCCUPIED
VERSUS RENTAL HOUSING STOCK.
DO THE INCREASED COST OF THE
LINK THE APPROVAL PROCESS AS A
NONPROFIT BUILDER IT'S COSTING
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS MORE EACH YEAR JUST TO
DO THE SAME THING IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING HOMES.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP RAISE
MORE FROM PRIVATE INVESTORS AND
LEVERAGE MORE FUNDING. TO FILL
THE GROWING GAP HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL AND
LEVERAGING RDA FUNDS AND THIS
INCENTIVE COULD HELP FILL THAT
VOID.
ADDITIONALLY IT WORKS WELL FOR
COMMUNITIES OF ALL SIZES URBAN
AND RURAL WITH A HUGE IMPACT IN
SMALLER MARKETS WHERE NON
PROFITS REALLY STRUGGLE TO
FUNDRAISE.
WE HAVE TO GET CREATIVE TO SOLVE
OUR HOUSING CRISIS AND THE SMART
TAX CREDIT IS ONE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOME PRODUCTION.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO WE
KNOW IT WILL HELP OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OTHER NONPROFIT
BUILDERS CLOSE THE FUNDING GAP.
INCREASE PRODUCTION AND SERVE
MORE OF OUR HARD WORKING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
MISTER CHAIR HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IS GRATEFUL
FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION AND WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WHEN ASKED IF THERE
ARE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
YES NICOLO DELUCA HERE WE HAVE
THE CITY OF OAKLAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SAYS THE MAD AT WHAT HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE FOR CALIFORNIA BE
IN SUPPORT.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION.
MOTION WITH THE BILLS ARE SECOND.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING THIS AGAIN -- THE I'VE
SUPPORT OF THIS IN THE PAST AND
WE SUPPORT OF THIS BEFORE --
HOPE YOU WILL HAVE BETTER
FORTUNE WITH IT THIS YEAR -- THE
ONE THING I MAY WANT TO ASK YOU
GUYS TO THINK ABOUT BUT THIS IS
NOT FOR CONSIDERATION TODAY IS I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER TO CáC
THE CALIFORNIA.
TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE
SHOULD ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM SO
THAT THE CREDITS CAN BE DIRECTED
TOWARD.
PROJECTS WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS
I KNOW YOU ARE CONTEMPLATING
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING FOR US
TO CONSIDER DISCUSSING IN THE
FUTURE BUT CERTAINLY FOR
PURPOSES OF TODAY I THINK THIS
BILLS IN GOOD SHAPE AND AND
SHOULD CONTINUE TO THE PROCESS.
AND WITH THAT UNLESS THERE ARE
ANY FINAL COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
MATURED ALSO COMMITTEE WE ARE.
A REACHING OUT TO BOTH ENTITIES --
FOR THAT CONSIDERATION -- AT THE
PRESENT TIME WE WAITING TO HAVE
A MEETING AND TO CONFIRM -- WHO
WOULD BE THE BEST OVERSIGHT FOR
THE FOR THIS PROJECT -- AND
THANK THE COMEDIAN THANK THE
CHAIRMAN CALIFORNIA IS NOW HOME
TO NEARLY A QUARTER OF THE
COUNTRY'S ENTIRE HOMELESS I'M
POPULATION DESPITE BEING.
DESPITE MAKING UP 12% OF THE
UNITED STATES POPULATION AS A
WHOLE REASONS REASONS -- CENSUS
FIGURES SHOW THAT THE STATE ALSO
HAS THE HIGHEST POVERTY RATE --
IN THE NATION BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE HOPE THE HOUSING CRISIS.
IN CALIFORNIA MY BILL
INCENTIVIZE THE GROWTH OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
PROVIDING ME -- MEANINGFUL
SOLUTIONS TO THOSE WHO STRUGGLE
TO FIND STABLE HOUSING -- THEY
CAN AFFORD WITHOUT HAVING TO
PULL FROM OTHER FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS HOUSING IS A
FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN RIGHT.
A HUMAN RIGHTS AND ALSO --
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ALSO HEALTH
AND WEALTH AND WEALTH WELLNESS --
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM TO MISTER
GIBSON'S ITEM.
MOTION TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS TO
HI.
I GAVE HI I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE KILEY LEE MON.
LIMóN HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
YOU HAVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT YOUR
BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALL EXCEL
ENTERTAINMENT XIN FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM.
MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY.
FILE ITEM FOR AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO IS A CONSENT ITEM IT
PASSED TO CONSENT TO HI.
I DAVE.
HI GABRIEL [inaudible]
MR GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA AYE
KILEY.
LEE MON THE MAN I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I SENT ITEMS PASS
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR FILE
ITEM ONE AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
SOME OF THEIR SECOND
[inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED. TWO
HI CHIU I STATE.
I GABRIELLE GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY [inaudible]
LEE MON.
LIMóN I'D MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE FILE AND
THREE A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
BLOOM ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
[inaudible]
SECOND -- MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED CHIU
AYE AYE.
HI I GABRIELLE GABRIELLE I
GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY LEE MON.
WE MIGHT I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI THAT ITEM IS ALSO
OUT BEFORE WE DOUBLE DOWN TODAY
I WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
BIRTHDAY OF SOMEONE HERE IN THE
ROOM WHO IS TURNING.
EIGHTY HER NAME IS JUDY WORTH
TIME IN ADDITION TO BEING AN
AMAZING HUMAN BEING SHE ALSO
HAPPENS TO BE THE MOTHER.
OF OUR CONSULTANTS THE WARTIME
HAPPY BIRTHDAY [inaudible]
AND AND WITH THAT OUR BUSINESS
IS DONE WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES FOR
ONE FINAL MEMBER BUT OTHERWISE
OUR BUSINESS IS COMPLETE FOR THE
DAY
.
AT THIS TIME THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED